[Music]
in this video we will showcase to you
all the times godzilla had a different
origin story so we all know godzilla as
one of the most iconic and most durable
fictional creatures to ever be created
for the big screen
and with his 30-plus films he usually
comes out from the ocean and terrorizes
humanity
and also the other kaiju as well
godzilla is depicted as an enormous
destructive prehistoric sea monster
awakened and empowered by nuclear
radiation with the nuclear bombings of
hiroshima and nagasaki and the lucky
dragon 5 incident
still fresh in the japanese
consciousness godzilla was conceived as
a metaphor for nuclear weapons
but this isn't always the case there are
other
origin stories that differ vastly from
the original and here in this video we
shall explore all the seven origin
stories
number one the irradiated sea reptile in
the original 1954 godzilla film
it is firstly proposed that godzilla was
a type of prehistoric intermediary
reptile related to both
land and sea reptiles that slept under
the water
for millions of years feeding on deep
sea organisms before being disturbed
and enhanced by an american hydrogen
bomb test
in the movie dr yamane proposes that the
original godzilla
might have been living among others of
his kind prior to the detonation
but the hydrogen bomb completely
destroyed his home and drew him out
he would have been a very large creature
to start with and the enhancement made
him into the nearly indestructible kaiju
that was only killed by a new super
weapon called the oxygen destroyer
a weapon that reacts violently with
water isolating oxygen molecules and
splitting them
this means that any organism exposed to
the chemical
will first suffocate from the lack of
oxygen and then disintegrate
the same thing that happened to godzilla
in the movie
number two the irradiated godzillasaurus
in this next origin story the first
after a very long time godzilla was
given a little bit of change in how he
came to be
he wasn't a deep sea reptile but a
modern day dinosaur
still living in an island so in the
movie it started in 1992 when a science
fiction writer
named kenichiro teresawa was writing a
book about godzilla
and then learns of a group of japanese
soldiers that when
they were stationed on lagos island
during the gilbert and marshall islands
campaign during the world war ii
in february 1944 while threatened by the
american soldiers and they were almost
overrun by the us military
the japanese soldiers were saved by a
mysterious dinosaur called
godzillasaurus he theorizes that the
dinosaur was subsequently mutated into
godzilla in 1954
after a hydrogen bomb test on the island
then
a wealthy businessman who commanded the
japanese soldiers on lagos island
confirms that the dinosaur did indeed
exist
number three the irradiated iguana in
this next origin story we go over the
ocean into the united states
also known as the american godzilla or
tristar godzilla this design by cat
luigi
is that of a hunched bent over marine
iguana but had the stance of dinosaurs
specifically the t-rex and other large
two-legged carnivorous theropods the
tristar godzilla is a 60 meter tall
creature
that is a mutation of a c iguana caused
by nuclear radiation
it was originally a marine iguana egg
irradiated by
french nuclear tests in french polynesia
it makes its presence known
years later when it attacks three
fishing boats in the ocean
the radiation in his body led to a slow
evolution into the lizard-like creature
seen running loose in new york city
during the events of the film
the transformation occurred over a
30-year period and this godzilla relies
on his speed and animalistic cunning to
evade attackers
and ambush them rather than fight them
head-on like the classic godzilla's
number four world war ii spirits in the
movie godzilla
mothra and king ghidorah giant monsters
all out attack
or gmk the godzilla that came out stands
out as a truly evil supernatural entity
back then japan suffered an attack from
godzilla and the monster laid waste to
tokyo transforming
of the one sprout capital of japan into
ground zero of a nuclear disaster
overnight
godzilla was killed with an experimental
chemical weapon
while the weapons inventor took his own
life to ensure that this weapon could
never be used again
but over the next several decades
humanity gradually began to forget about
godzilla
with many assuming that the creature
never existed and was simply a legend
in the film godzilla was indeed killed
by the oxygen destroyer in 1954 but his
body wasn't destroyed
it became possessed by the souls of the
people who died in the pacific ocean
during world war ii
in this movie ghidorah was actually the
good guy can you believe it
number five the titan super species
in legendary stake on the g-man he was a
very ancient life form
a titan super species that was on the
planet for hundreds of millions of years
ago
but it wasn't something like the earlier
origin stories where an ancient life
form
was mutated by nuclear weapons he was
initially thought to be a threat
and now we understand his potential to
become the world's ultimate guardian
a towering apex predator emerging from
the mysterious depths of the ocean to
battle aggressors
that threaten the balance of nature
millions of years ago as the planet
cooled down
and its natural atmospheric radiation
began to decrease
after the permian triassic extinction
event he adapted to survive various
other extinction events by diving deep
into the ocean
and consuming the planet's natural
geothermal radiation
in a hibernation-like state from its
molten core until 1945
when the atomic bombing of hiroshima
woke him up along with a fearsome
shinomura
another titan which was also an enemy he
previously fought in the past
during the permanent period number six
a hyper-evolving sea creature in the new
2016 shin godzilla movie
the origins of the g-man shifted from
reptile to an unknown creature which
many believe to be some sort of ancient
frilled shark
here godzilla is not born out of the
dropping of a nuclear bomb
but rather out of nuclear waste dumped
in the sea
godzilla like most monsters if not all
is a monster that humans make directly
or maybe indirectly we learn it was
created when a marine animal consumes
nuclear waste
dumped by the united states and the sea
once again
nuclear waste and victims lie at the
origin story of godzilla
these marine animals were ancient live
forms that continued to exist till the
present day
and this origin was similar to that of
destroyer in which ancient sea life
forms were exposed to the oxygen
destroyer weapon
and hence mutated them but it was
nuclear waste for shin
he then went on to evolve four times and
actually eight times to become
a god in the memo and earlier official
plans
number seven mutated plant species
this is by far the weirdest and the most
deviant
of all the origin stories of the g-man
he is the largest
on-screen incarnation of the character
to date standing at more than 300 meters
or more than 1 000 feet tall this
incarnation of godzilla first appeared
in the year 2030
at which point mankind had already
endured over a quarter of a century of
repeated attacks
from huge creatures called kaiju
godzilla then established himself as the
most powerful kaiju
eliminating everything else including
humans this incarnation of godzilla is
unique
in that he originated from planned life
rather than animal life
he is said to be the end result of
natural selection on earth
godzilla evolved as a result of his
planned life
incorporating the characteristics of
various other organisms
through a process of horizontal gene
transfer
granting him extreme durability heat
resistance
stealthiness regenerative abilities and
other attack
powers like the atomic breath
so now that we come to the end of the
video do tell us what you think about
the different origin stories
was the irradiated godzillasaurus
actually the same animal as the deepsea
reptile
of the original storyline also what do
you think about the origins of shin
godzilla
and whether his beginnings are really
similar to that of destoroya
and yes what about the strange godzilla
earth's origins
he was actually a plan and not an animal
nevertheless a reptile
anyway do hit that like subscribe and
bell button for regular updates